[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number 95
of the weekly "Google
Cloud Platform Podcast."
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm so much
more awake than you are.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know!
This is my second
Monday this week, and--
[LAUGHTER]
--it is hard.
I just flew back from Sydney,
landed a couple hours ago.
So yes, indeed, I am very,
very, very jet lagged.
MARK MANDEL: So
podcast listeners,
say thank you to Francesc.
Send him tweets.
Send him pictures of puppies.
He came directly
from the airport
just so we could
record an episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I may not read them,
because I might be
sleeping by the time you
send those pictures.
But yeah, I think
it's going to be
worth it, because we
have a lot of really
cool things of the week.
There's some of the cool
things of the week today
that I'm very,
very excited about.
And then for the
main content, we're
going to have a friend of mine--
Quinn Slack-- he's a CEO and
co-founder of Sourcegraph.
And Sourcegraph is a company
that they use Go, basically,
and they allow you to
kind of like advance
navigation of source code,
but directly in your browser.
And it is really cool.
It works not only for Go,
but for many languages.
And the infrastructure behind
also runs on Google Cloud.
So he's going to come
and explain a little bit
about all of the cool things
they do, and how they do it,
and why they do it that way.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and
finally, after that,
we will have our question of the
week talking about, basically,
how do I remove personally
identifiable information?
Say I have a stream of
data coming from outside,
so user-generated content--
what can I do to get rid of
that in an automated fashion?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it
is an interesting question
with a very, very
interesting answer.
It's an API.
But that will be later.
So we're going to go
directly with the cool things
of the week, then.
The first one-- and I am very,
very excited about this one,
because I've been waiting
for it for quite a while--
it is that we
finally have managed
SSL for Google App Engine.
And what that means is that
now you do not need to create
or even manage your HTTPS
certificates for App Engine
when you're using
custom domains.
Until right now, if
you got an address
that was something.appspot.com
and that one came with HTTPS
automatically, but
if you were trying
to do something else like
GCPPodcast.com, for instance,
you needed to manage that.
Now you don't need
to do that anymore.
Everything is automated
and everyone is happy.
MARK MANDEL: Arr,
it's fantastic!
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Oh, yeah, also--
[LAUGHTER]
--oh, wow, that was really bad.
It's another cool
thing of the week.
Today is Talk Like a Pirate Day.
MARK MANDEL: I had to
slip that in there.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: It
is a very bad joke.
What's the favorite programming
language of pirates?
MARK MANDEL: R!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: R!
Exactly.
MARK MANDEL: That
is a terrible joke.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I know,
but it's totally on topic.
Anyway, we have a
second cool thing
of the week that comes from
our friends at Spotify.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so Spotify
has been working directly
with the GCP security
team, releasing a product
called Forseti.
Forseti's really cool.
It's an open-source tool that
enables you to basically do
several things over your
Google Cloud Platform project.
Basically, if you think
about it in terms of--
I'm going to deploy
a bunch of stuff
onto Google Cloud
Platform, but I
want to ensure that
I have visibility
into exactly what's
happening but then
also be able to scan and
enforce certain security
rules about what I
want to have happen.
So say, for example, I want
to have certain firewall
rules across, maybe,
my GCE instances
or other things like that.
This gives me a way
to basically be like,
OK, let's look at what's
available inside our system.
Let's see if it has the
rules that are applied to it.
And if they're
not applied to it,
let's make sure that
those things are there
and make sure that
that happens, which
is security good and stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I really like it,
because if you have enough
instances, these kind of things
will happen.
Someone will forget.
Someone will be doing a
little test and open SSH port
and then forget about it.
And then now you have
an attack vector.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and even
if you're automating it
with Ansible or Chef or Puppet,
maybe something goes wrong,
it's just an extra layer
there to basically say,
let's just make sure this
is always locked down.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And it's
not only just warning,
but you can actually say, OK,
just drop that added rule.
Close that port.
So perfect.
It's very, very nice, and
completely open source.
And I wonder if it's
[? read and ?] [? go. ?]
It's probably [? read and go. ?]
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
While you're looking that up,
I will talk about the last one.
There's a "Medium" article by--
I'm going to read the name
off of the post, here--
Christopher "Grah-nt,"
or possibly Grant,
depending on which
country he comes from--
talking about building
global Kubernetes in three
steps on Google Cloud Platform.
I particularly like this,
because I was literally
reading this morning
about how to set up
federated clusters
in Kubernetes,
and I was pulling my hair
out trying to work out,
what's just the simple
steps for how to do this?
He's written a
"Medium" post that
shows you how to use
KubFed, basically just
step by step by step.
This is how you set up
each of the clusters.
This is how you create
aliases for them,
join them up, and then
deploy your application
across the several clusters that
span the globe, which was just
super nice to use.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
It's raining Python.
MARK MANDEL: It's
raining Python.
It's OK, you'll live.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, very sad.
No, Python is cool, too.
Anyway, I think
it's time to go talk
to Quinn about Sourcegraph.
MARK MANDEL: Let's do that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I
am very happy, today,
to welcome to the
podcast Quinn Slack.
He's the CEO of a company
called Sourcegraph
that I think I've talked
about many times before.
And he's here to
tell us a little bit
about what they
do at Sourcegraph
and how they use Google Cloud.
So hello, Quinn.
How are you doing?
QUINN SLACK: Hey,
I'm doing great.
Thanks for having me on.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Thank you for coming.
We're going to be talking a
lot about all of the things
that you do at Sourcegraph.
It's a very interesting
company, especially--
in the Go community
you're pretty well-known.
But before we start
with that, why don't you
tell us a little bit
about who you are
and what do you
do at Sourcegraph.
QUINN SLACK: All right,
I am, again, Quinn.
And I'm the founder
and CEO of Sourcegraph.
We build a universal
code browser.
So if you're a
developer and you work
with tons and tons of
code-- reading code,
writing code-- across a
lot of different projects,
then we have a product
that helps you do that.
It makes it much
easier to read code,
to jump around, get all
the IDE-like features--
whether you're on GitHub,
whether you're reading code
elsewhere on the web, across all
the projects of your company.
We have customers with
thousands of repositories.
We have users who
jump around 10,
20, 30 open-source repositories.
Our product makes that a
lot easier for you to read.
MARK MANDEL: So OK, so this
sounds quite interesting,
what it is that you work on.
But can you give
us a higher level--
how is this different
from, say, somebody
using just a regular
IDE or searching
for something in GitHub?
QUINN SLACK: Different
in a few ways.
So your IDE is optimized
for editing code--
and usually, in one project.
And maybe 10, 20 years
ago, if you're a developer,
you could just be
working in one project.
But these days, you have to use
so much open-source code or so
many other micro
services in your company,
and the job of a developer
has just gotten a lot harder.
So we built a product
from the ground up
that actually understands
cross-repository references,
linkages.
So you can point to
any piece of code.
You can say, show me everywhere
in the open-source world--
or everywhere in my company--
this thing is being called.
You can instantly search
across all your repositories--
hundreds or thousands of
repositories-- at any version.
You don't need to wait
for them to be indexed.
And so the tools that we
have as developers today--
I think they solve the problems
we had maybe 10 years ago.
But with the explosion of
open source, micro services,
a lot more things, the job
has just gotten a lot harder.
And we're building the
tools to help developers
solve these problems today.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
And that basically
is a web application
where people can browse
the code on everything,
but it's also a Chrome
extension, right?
QUINN SLACK: Right.
So you can get Sourcegraph
on the desktop,
and that is something
that you download.
And you can browse
all your local code.
You can browse remote code.
And it's a universal
code browser.
It makes all the world's code
transparently available to you.
And inside of
that, of course, we
have language
analyzers-- which we
call language servers-- built
on Microsoft's Language Server
Protocol, which is
the new standard.
It was released
about a year ago,
and already you have
servers for most languages,
and it's a really
cool new standard.
We have a lot of people work
on language servers internally,
and a lot of other people
at other companies and--
then, yeah, you can
access it on the desktop.
You can get it in our
Chrome extension on GitHub.
So you can be viewing
code on GitHub.
You can be looking
at a pull request,
and you put your mouse over
any token, and you get a hover.
You can do Find References.
You can do Go To Definition.
And you can get it integrated
into your own editor.
You can get it on the CLI, and
you can get it on a web app.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I really like--
that Chrome extension is
something that I use daily.
Whenever I visit
GitHub and it's not on,
I just feel like
GitHub is broken,
because there's no hover.
And then I realize that, oh,
yeah, it's not part of GitHub.
It's actually part
of Sourcegraph.
It's a very cool tool.
OK, so I think that with
this, pretty much people
have a pretty good idea
of what Sourcegraph does
and what is the use case.
So let's get into tech.
So OK, so you have
some clients--
desktop client, web client--
and then you have some servers.
Where are those servers running?
QUINN SLACK: Good question.
The servers are running
on Google Cloud--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's good.
QUINN SLACK: --and
in Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So is that on GKE--
on Google Container Engine?
QUINN SLACK: Yeah, it's
on GKE, and we love it.
We decided a couple years
ago to go all Kubernetes.
Can go into a bunch
of different reasons,
both technical and
business reasons.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, give us one.
QUINN SLACK: All right.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, please do.
QUINN SLACK: So I am the CEO
and founder, but I'm also a dev
and I've been coding
for a long time.
So I get to see both reasons
why we made this choice.
First, let's start out
with the technical reasons
for making the choice.
There's the developer
aesthetic reason.
You look at
Kubernetes, and you can
tell that it's a deployment
system just built
by people who've been thinking
about this problem for a decade
or more.
And Google understands
how to build a solution
to this problem better than
probably any other company
out there.
All these little things that
we never would have thought
of in our own
deployment system--
and other systems
wouldn't have thought of--
Kubernetes has addressed.
Or you can look at the
roadmap, and you know
they're going to address it.
Love that it's written in Go,
that you can read the code,
that the CLI is really good.
I just feel like it was
built for people like us.
And the other technical
reason is just--
it works very well.
It was easy to get
up and running.
It is well-documented.
It's a standard tool.
And then, of course,
we tried it out locally
and we wanted to see where
we could deploy this,
and we saw that Google
Cloud-- obviously, they
have native support
for Kubernetes,
and you get the feeling
that Google Cloud was
built with Kubernetes in mind.
So that's why we went with
it for technical reasons.
Cool.
So you sound like
you're doing a bit more
than, say, your standard web
app or something like that.
How are you using Kubernetes?
Are you using it
in stateless ways?
for stateful ways?
Are you using deployment?
StatefulSets?
How-- are you
using the Jobs API?
How are you using GKE?
We started using it two years
ago when a lot of these things
were not available, and we
have a few design decisions
we made with our application
that make things easier for us.
We actually don't need
to store a lot of state.
So when you go on Sourcegraph
and you mouseover something
and you see a hover,
that's actually
being served in real time
from a language server
process running somewhere
in our Kubernetes cluster.
So not a lot of state.
And the tiny amount of data
that we do need to store,
it's either one index around
cross-browser references,
or just a cache.
So we have our web server
frontend process running.
That has GraphQL
and WebSocket APIs.
The WebSocket one is for the
language server protocol.
We have a proxy that the web
server will send a language
server request to, and then
the proxy will figure out,
do I need to spin up
another Go process
or Go Server to serve that?
And then it'll send it to one
of the language server backends,
and that will fetch all the
repo data from our GET server,
also running in the same
cluster in Kubernetes.
And it'll do all the
language analysis,
whether that's in Go or Java
or TypeScript or Python or C#
or whatever, and it'll return
back through the web socket
and back to the client.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So I'm wondering-- you mentioned
that you like Kubernetes partly
because [? it's read and ?]
[? go. ?] Is Sourcegraph also
[? read and ?] [? go? ?]
QUINN SLACK: Oh, yeah.
From day one, we wrote
Sourcegraph in Go.
And initially, we chose
Go because Sourcegraph
is something that
understands source code,
and Go has amazing libraries--
even in the standard
library-- for understanding
its own source code.
So it was the natural choice.
And we also had been coming--
my co-founder and
I-- from jobs where
we were writing other languages,
which will not be named.
And Go is really nice
to start working in.
And since then, we've
grown to other languages.
We still love Go.
We still write all
of our stuff in Go,
but we have customers
and users across a bunch
of different other languages.
And generally, when we write
the Python language server,
we'll do that in Python.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
QUINN SLACK: So we are polyglot,
but we have a special place
in our heart for Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
I guess that's also
one of the benefits of
running in Kubernetes,
is no matter what
language you have,
you put it into a Go container
and then you're ready to go.
QUINN SLACK: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
QUINN SLACK: Yeah, so I want
to talk about the business
reasons, too, for Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Oh, go for it!
QUINN SLACK: Yep.
As you know, I got
to think about both.
And our product
is obviously loved
by a lot of people
in open source,
but it is for companies.
It is for companies
with a lot of code.
And for those companies,
it is important to them
that their code stays secure.
It's important that they run
a lot of their core services
in their own infrastructure.
And it is a really important
business decision for us--
how we deliver our software
to these customers.
We wanted to make
sure that we built it
so that it is so
easy for a customer
to run Sourcegraph internally.
And that meant not being
tied to any specific vendor's
way of deploying or
orchestrating an application.
So if we have customers across
all different kinds of Clouds,
then by using Kubernetes,
that is the standard.
And it's not the case that every
single one of our customers
is already using Kubernetes
and we can just slot that in.
But it is a very easy
sell to them to say,
we are built on Kubernetes
and we'll ship this to you
as a Helm chart.
And luckily our
audience is developers,
and so they get that.
And even if they're not
using Kubernetes now,
they can sense that they will
be using it in the future.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, you
just stole my question.
I was going to ask you--
because you were saying, well,
one of the reasons is-- we want
to run it in Kubernetes so it's
easy to install it
and run it anywhere
where they have Kubernetes.
And you mentioned
Helm, which I love.
We had an episode on
Helm some time ago.
I'm sure you can find
it if you search for it.
Why are you using Helm?
Tell us a little bit more
about the experience using it.
I'm curious.
QUINN SLACK: Well, I don't
know as much about Helm.
I am a user of it.
I was not the person who
created our Helm charts.
That was one of our
teammates, Richard,
who also works on GopherJS--
the Go JavaScript compiler.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, cool.
QUINN SLACK: Yeah.
You should direct any
questions on that to him.
He's the expert on that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Really cool.
So for those that are
interested in Helm,
we actually had an
episode-- according to Mark.
Thank you, Mark.
MARK MANDEL: That's all right.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Episode 50.
We have Michelle Noorali
and Matthew Butcher.
So go check it out if
you're curious about Helm.
I say that Helm is basically
APT-GET for Kubernetes.
I don't know if
that's correct or not,
but I like to say
it's like that.
MARK MANDEL: That's correct.
Cool.
So it sounds like you're using,
basically, open source, which
is awesome, for running
your applications.
What are you using
for monitoring?
Are you using our stuff, or
do you use something else?
QUINN SLACK: We use
LightStep, which
is based on the open-source
protocol for tracing.
And we've instrumented
our language servers,
our Go servers, and even
some of our infrastructure,
to just send up traces.
And I know that that was built
by some former Google Cloud
people, and it's
based on a system
that you guys have at Google.
So I'd like to think
that it's still somewhat
in the Google Cloud family,
but we love LightStep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
At some point, you mentioned
a little bit about the fact
that you were
storing some cache.
Where are you
storing-- in general?
What kind of storage are
you using for Sourcegraph?
QUINN SLACK: We have
a couple pods that
have Postgres servers in
our Kubernetes cluster,
and they do not use any
special kind of persistence.
If those end up dying
for whatever reason,
then they'll just
come right back up
and we'll kick off
the indexing jobs.
We built everything
about our infrastructure
so that if the data went away--
even if the global index went
away-- that we could
recreate it in minutes, even
for all of the open-source
code that matters.
So system design was
really important.
If we hadn't
optimized the system
to be super fast on the fly for
answering any specific question
and to do only the minimal
amount of computation
necessary to answer
that question,
then I think we would have to
think more about persistence.
We'd have to at least
have our Kubernetes
setup be a lot more complex.
It'd be a lot more fragile.
But because we built our system
around not persisting data,
it makes our job a lot easier.
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
And I know, as well, you said
you've got a Chrome plug-in.
I know you've also got
some IDE integrations.
How are you making
that connection,
monitoring that connection,
checking latency?
How is that whole pathway
from, I'm going to assume GKE,
up into the browser and/or
your IDE integrations, as well?
QUINN SLACK: This is one of
those classic CS interview
questions.
Tell me everything
that happens when
you type in www.Google.com.
So from the user's
point of view,
they have our Chrome extension,
and they go to GitHub.
They put their mouse over,
say, a function call.
What happens there is that will
issue just a normal HTTP post
request to our servers.
A post request-- it's like a
single-shot LSP session using
the Language Server
Protocol to say,
hey, get me this
hover for this file,
and this repo at this character.
That will go to our
frontend server,
and then that will open a web
socket via this language server
proxy that we have to the
language server backend.
It'll spin up a language server
for that repo with that commit,
fetch the files.
Again, fetching
the minimum set of
files necessary to
answer that question.
And then it'll return
the data, and you'll just
get a single HTTP
response on the client.
And then you'll show
that in a little tooltip.
MARK MANDEL: So now I'm
just actually curious--
that WebSocket connection,
is that internal,
or is that to the browser?
QUINN SLACK: It
depends on the client.
Our Chrome extension doesn't
open a WebSocket to our server.
And if you're on Sourcegraph.com
or our desktop app,
then that will open a WebSocket.
No good reason for doing
WebSocket versus not,
other than we look at
average duration of session.
And we can optimize
it a little bit better
if it's just a single
HTTP post request,
then we know that
we can clean up
the resources when that's done.
And generally,
the average number
of hovers that someone does
in our Chrome extension
is less than the
number of hovers
they do on an average
Sourcegraph.com session.
Just some internal
stuff like that.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So still talking about the
same topic of how you connect
from your clients
to your servers,
you said that
you're using mostly
either HTTP requests
like one-off requests,
or using WebSockets.
I'm curious, are
you using HTTP/2?
Why not HTTP/2 with streaming
or maybe even gRPC on top of it?
QUINN SLACK: Well,
we do use HTTP/2.
We have the server do push
for some of our assets.
And that results in a
pretty nice performance
increase on the initial load.
We use WebSockets for
LSP, because there
were good libraries
to do that already.
We used to use gRPC
for some things like,
fetch me a list of
the repositories
that a user can view.
But so much of the
client activity
was occurring from
browser clients.
And at the time, gRPC
didn't have good support--
either for issuing
requests or for making
a RESTful API, which we still
needed for other reasons.
The gRPC HTTP gateway project
looked super exciting,
but by the time that we needed
some things out of our API
that it didn't support, it
wasn't far enough along.
MARK MANDEL: That
seems reasonable.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So we've talked a little bit
about monitoring and tracing
and all of these
things will generate
a decent amount of data.
So, I'm curious about what
do you do with that data
afterwards?
QUINN SLACK: Well, for things
like performance tracing
and event logging, we use
other services like LightStep
that just collect all the data,
and we offload that to them.
This is for Sourcegraph.com
so this is Cloud data.
It's just sent over
gRPC protocol using open
tracing to LightStep,
and then we
can see, actually,
for any operation that
occurs on the site what was the
entire trace of every operation
that happened.
There's actually
a debug setting,
if you are an intrepid
Sourcegraph user where
you can turn on the ability
to get little LightStep links
to any operation you perform.
And there have been some
times when we've asked users
to turn that on and it's been
super useful to collect that.
MARK MANDEL: Do you store
it in any intermediary step?
Do you use Google Cloud Storage,
or is it just sent directly off
to your third-party services?
QUINN SLACK: Yeah, right
now some of the logs
are stored in a bucket
on Google Cloud Storage,
and then that gets
ingested into BigQuery.
We have some other
intermediate jobs
to associate different
machines' log data,
apply other transformations
to it, normalizations.
And then that gets
into BigQuery.
And then on top of BigQuery, we
will run some automated queries
on BigQuery to do reporting,
and that shows up in our Slack.
And we'll also look at the data
through a bunch of dashboards
that we've created on Looker.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So does that mean that most
of the logging that you do
is structured logging?
QUINN SLACK: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So you're logging
structurally, you
send it to BigQuery, and just
keep it there for reports.
But do you ever use
it as a debug tool
to figure out what happened to
a request, or not that much?
QUINN SLACK: Not that much.
Maybe everyone thinks that
they're special in this way,
but because so much of
our system is real time,
there's not a lot
of persistent data.
For most things, we can
reproduce the issues
by just running things
locally because it
doesn't depend on state
that's stored somewhere else.
And we've built our
system so that we
have a lot of test
cases of, here
is a really complicated
Java project.
Can you produce the right
hover for this token?
And we try to make everything
a pure function as much
as possible.
So we were actually just
talking with someone
else who runs ops for a
pretty big company elsewhere
in San Francisco, and he was
asking how much of your day
is spent on ops fire drills
and p zeroes and all that.
And I showed him our ops log
where we record every p zero,
and there are not a lot of them.
I think that's because of the
way that we built our system,
and because we built it on a
bunch of primitive components
that work really well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Because
it's written in Go.
QUINN SLACK: Yeah, well,
there are no bugs in Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Of course.
QUINN SLACK: Except
when I write it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So now I'm
curious about open source.
You mentioned that
you're running--
most of the thing is written
in Go, which is open source.
Runs in Kubernetes,
which is open source.
You used to use gRPC--
not anymore, but gRPC
has also open source.
What about other projects?
Have you considered things
like Prometheus, Istio?
What do you think about them?
QUINN SLACK: Yeah,
we do use Prometheus.
We use Graphite, and we use
a lot of open-source language
servers.
We have released a lot of
open-source language servers
for language analysis.
And we have a bunch of other
open-source projects that are
on GitHub.com/Sourcegraph
that various people are using,
mostly in Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cool, and all of this
is in Sourcegraph
on GitHub directly?
GitHub.com/Sourcegraph?
QUINN SLACK: That's it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Easy, OK, cool.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
This all sounds super cool.
I'll ask one question
as well, because now I'm
just interested in Sourcegraph,
and I've never really played
with it.
If I want to play with
Sourcegraph, where do I start?
Can I just use it on
GitHub for free, on that?
Or do I have to pay?
How do I play with this thing
if I'm quite keen on it?
QUINN SLACK: Yeah,
Sourcegraph is
totally free for open source,
so just Go and Sourcegraph.com.
You can sign up, and then you
can just start clicking around
on your repositories.
Or just go to the Chrome Web
Store, type in Sourcegraph,
get our Chrome extension,
and then just start
looking at code on GitHub.
If you want to look
at private code,
then you'll obviously
have to log in.
But for open-source code,
it's just going to work.
Just put your mouse over a
token and you'll see the hover.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I cannot
recommend that enough.
Just adding the
Chrome extension makes
GitHub so much easier to use.
Things like Go To
Definition on a web page--
it just blows my mind.
So useful.
QUINN SLACK: Yeah, we
think that developers
deserve things like Go To
Definition, Find References--
all these things
anywhere they're
looking at code, whether it's
in their browser, their editor,
random other web pages.
It should be like water.
It should be always available.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I'm going to ask one more
question that might be
a complicated question to ask.
But we just did an
episode on Kubernetes 1.7,
and there was a lot
of new features.
Do you know if there's
any of these features that
are interesting for you?
Or are you more like a
core usage of Kubernetes,
like services and stuff?
QUINN SLACK: I don't know.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's totally fine.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, well,
before we wrap up,
is there anything that we
haven't managed to mention,
or something you want to plug?
Maybe events you'll be at,
or particularly cool things
you've seen from
Sourcegraph that you
think will be on the
podcast before we finish up?
QUINN SLACK: Well, I want to
just plug GopherCon, which
we went to a few months ago.
We had a fantastic time.
We had a bunch of
Sourcegraphers there,
met a lot of our
users and customers.
We did something
that was really fun,
and I would encourage
everyone listening
to participate in the future.
We live blogged the conference.
So we would just
sit in the talk,
and we'd be typing as
the person was talking.
And at the end, we'd
have a live blog post
that we could just
click Publish on.
And then everyone who couldn't
make it at the conference
could see what was going
on and follow along.
It was a ton of fun.
We got a lot of community
volunteers to do it.
And we're going be doing that
at a lot more conferences.
Dot Go will be one of
them, and other conferences
in other languages as well.
So if you hear of a
live blog going on,
then shoot us an
email if you want
to participate by writing
or even helping us edit.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
So thank you so much for being
so active in the Go community
and the open-source community.
But also, thank you so
much for being here today
and telling us a little
bit more about Sourcegraph
and what you do
with Google Cloud.
QUINN SLACK: Thank you.
Thank you for making it
so I can come and spend
some time with you
all instead of having
to deal with all the
ops and systems work.
You take care of
all that for us.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Awesome, thank you.
MARK MANDEL: So a
huge thanks to Quinn
for joining us on the podcast
to talk all about Sourcegraph.
Sounds like a super
interesting project.
I'm actually-- I'm a
huge IntelliJ user.
They've got integrations with
everything, as we talked about,
so I'm keen to get it installed
and see what interesting stuff
it can find out about my source,
and give me some nice hints
on what I can do with it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
For me, really, it is just
the integration with Chrome
that allows me to just
browse code on GitHub
in a much easier way,
to the point that when
I use another profile
where it is not installed,
it just feels like
something is missing.
So that's a good thing
for an extension.
Anyway, it's time to go with
our question of the week.
And the question of the
week is basically, OK,
so I have information, and
I'm storing information,
but some of that information
should not be stored.
Let's say that you have
a chat, for instance,
and normally, you expect
people to talk to you
and tell you things.
And one of the things
that you may ask
is, oh, just to make sure
that you're the right person,
please give me the last four
digits of your credit card
or your social security number.
The last four digits.
And someone, by mistake,
gives the whole thing.
MARK MANDEL: Oops.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: What
do you do then, right?
You cannot just store that.
MARK MANDEL: No, that's bad.
Or somebody sends a photo
of their license, maybe.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
There's a lot of
information that is private.
Or even more than that.
You can have things like IPs.
Or a lot of information
that goes into logs,
you just really want to make
sure that those things are not
actually stored
and made persistent
so other people might
find them later on.
Also, it goes against some--
a bunch of rules, actually.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, there's a
bunch of compliance stuff--
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, a
bunch of compliance things
that [INAUDIBLE].
MARK MANDEL: All
right, so I don't
want to set up a huge
number of humans going
through all this stuff,
because that's obviously not
going to scale.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So--
MARK MANDEL: What tools
do I have available to me?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: TensorFlow.
MARK MANDEL: First,
we need the model.
I think that's the
answer to everything.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
You train the model.
Actually, you could
technically do it, right?
With TensorFlow, you train it
so it recognizes what a credit
card is, then recognizes what
a Social Security card looks
like, and start with that.
And then you would be able
to delete those things.
And that's what Google has done.
And rather than publishing
as a TensorFlow model,
it is simply an API.
So it's kind of like Cloud
Vision API, where you just send
an image and it classifies it.
In this case, what you do is you
can send either text or images.
And in the images, it
will find things inside
of the image and sense
or redact the part
that is actually PII, Personally
Identifiable Information.
When you're using it,
you can say exactly what
parts you want to redact.
So for instance,
you could say, I
do not consider faces to be
something that I should redact.
Or you could say,
actually, yes, if there's
a picture of anything, make sure
that there's no faces on it.
And there's things, for
instance, Google Street View.
You do not see faces
on Google Street View.
You could do the
same with this API.
It's very simple.
The cool thing is
that I actually
demoed this in Sydney
last week on Wednesday,
and it was lots of fun.
So we'll have a link on the show
notes so you can check it out.
It's a five-minute
demo, real quick.
But it ends up with a pretty
good joke, in my opinion.
I made it myself, so--
MARK MANDEL: So you're
a little biased.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I'm a little bit biased,
but I'd say it was
a pretty good joke.
People laughed, so.
But they were Australian.
Maybe they were just nice.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, maybe.
Maybe, maybe not.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, Australian
people are not that nice.
No, just kidding.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
All right, well, that sounds
like a great way of doing it.
And I've got a very
simple API that I
don't have to learn TensorFlow,
or do [INAUDIBLE] transforms,
or anything else like that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Everything
you need to learn is JSON.
MARK MANDEL: It's just JSON?
That sounds fantastic.
Awesome.
Well, Francesc, what are you
up to over the next few weeks?
Are you up to anything exciting?
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
More Cloud summits.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, fun.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
So just getting back from
Cloud Summit in Sydney.
Last week, also, we had
Cloud Summit in Seattle.
This week, there's Cloud Summit
in Kuala Lumpur in Singapore,
and I will not be there.
Instead, I'll be here
in San Francisco.
But next week,
there's Cloud Summit
in Chicago, Wednesday, 27th.
So if you're
around, let me know.
I love to meet more
people using Google Cloud
Platform, especially Gophers.
And after that, in October,
I'll be out to London
to speak at Velocity.
What about you?
MARK MANDEL: Nice, cool.
So when this comes
out, that will
be the day before Awesome
Game Conference, where
I will be speaking at
two different panels.
Doing one on Kubernetes
and game servers,
and then also doing a panel with
a variety of cloud providers.
We'll talk about
games in the cloud.
And then I'll be
attending Strange Loop,
just hanging out there.
Having some nice recovery
time at a very interesting
conference.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Jealous.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And then in October, I
will be going to Australia.
I'll be there for Melbourne
International Games
Week for Unite Melbourne,
so Game Connect Asia Pacific
as well as PAX Australia.
And I will also be doing the
GDG DevFest in Melbourne the day
before as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
I met a lot of people at
Cloud Summit in Sydney that
were big fans of the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Hi!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: And
they all knew your name.
MARK MANDEL: That's good.
That's good that some
people know my name.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So thanks so much for all of the
people that I met in Australia.
They were super nice and very
excited about the podcast.
It's nice to see--
MARK MANDEL: Meet people.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --real
people talking to you.
It's fun.
And thank you, Mark, for
taking the time today--
MARK MANDEL: Thank
you, Francesc,
for coming in all the
way from the airport.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --to help me go
through this hard thing, which
is recording an
episode jetlagged.
MARK MANDEL: Wonderful.
And we'll see you all next week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]